[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what's making the headlines with the
deputy editor of The Spectator Freddie
gray and the Daily Mirror columnist
Susie Boniface with us from now until
just before midnight welcome to both of
you so to the front pages then let's
start with the financial times which is
leading with criticisms of the bank of
England who have come under Fire since
the value of the pound hit its lowest
level since 1971.
Fury at the City Slickers betting
against UK PLC reads the front of the
Daily Mail which also leads with the
story
the Metro looks at the value of the
pound the headline the pound quartanks
Honey I Shrunk the quids raised the
front of the Daily Star
out of control is the headline on the
front of the Daily Mirror as the
conservative party's mini budget
continues to be under scrutiny
The Daily Express looks at the response
to criticisms of the mini budget with
the headline Don't Panic we've got a
plan to cut dead
the ice I also running with that story
their headline new mortgages blocked
amid UK Market turmoil and the front of
the telegraph also leading with the
headlines spooked lenders ditch new
mortgages in pound chaos
prime minister Liz truss's economic
strategy is questioned on the front page
of the Guardian
and reminded that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out those front
pages while you watch our guests so
let's uh return to them joined tonight
as I said by the deputy editor of The
Spectator Freddie gray and the Daily
Mirror columnist Susie Boniface and
Freddie that's not exactly a set of
headlines any Chancellor or prime
minister wants to wake up to come
Tuesday morning and how do we get
ourselves out of this
well it's it's a news horror a new cycle
horror for this government
um and as that ft front page suggests uh
the concern is that um the moves by the
treasury tonight and the bank of England
to calm the markets haven't uh appeared
to have worked very well I think the
ft's being and actually other papers too
are being slightly too uh apocalyptic
about it in that it's obviously a very
very bad day uh for Britain on the on
the global exchanges
um however you know if you look at the
beginning of the day it was one point
that the pound was 1.07 to the dollar at
the end of the day it's 1.08
um so that's not a massive slide
um but of course the guilt yields are
terrifyingly high and that's the real
story uh and that's the thing the
government wants to try and get under
control and seem to be struggling with
and what's very obvious
um is that the government did not
anticipate this reaction at all I think
they anticipated some uh Market
volatility but nothing like this
um Susie um reminding everybody that
quasi-quartang had told the Ft on Friday
that he would set out a medium-term
fiscal plan in the new year that's now
been brought forward to November the
23rd the office for Budget
responsibility announcing an independent
set of forecasts on the same day that's
still two months away though isn't it
yep but it's quite astonishing that you
know a Chancellor who's just stood up
and made a massive fiscal intervention
has to immediately find some way to to
sort it out within two months of it and
even so I think that's not going to be
early enough now this is the first time
uh that I can recall that any government
but certainly the conservatives being in
this much uh economic chaos since the
1990s since black Wednesday and I can't
remember at all in history even any
prime minister who has caused this much
trouble within a couple of months taking
over and I can't remember any chancellor
who just with a 20 minute
non-budget budget speech has managed to
do this to the market usually you know
when there's a huge problem financially
it's because there are external factors
there are other things happening in the
global markets and and our chancellor
has just reacted badly what's happened
here is entirely and 100
dependent upon the decisions that were
made in Downing Street by Liz truss and
quasiquarting it's not
um being impacted to a large extent by
anything else it's just down to these
guys and they can't blame you on someone
else they've talked about this being
Jitters in the city but actually this is
is because they have got billions and
billions of unfunded borrowing
um on the Never Never pretty much this
is exactly the kind of thing the
conservatives are warning us about for
years that you'd get with Jeremy corbyn
if you remember
um and because they didn't allow an
assessment by the the uh office of
budget responsibility and now today even
though the bank of England has issued
trying to issue some reassure Insurance
because they didn't immediately raise
interest rates that made the markets
even more jittery and it's going to cost
all our prices to go up it's as simple
as that and they can't blame anybody
else this is because they wanted to
appeal to a very narrow electorate the
conservative party membership and they
wanted to offer them tax cuts on the
minute they got in they gave them that
but that's the price you pay for
appealing to a very narrow fairly
selfish minority in order to get power
the Metro the pound for tanks and as
Cesar was saying there um Freddie
um you know the pound Falls Imports are
expensive we import lots of America for
example and some things like Metals you
know that they're in they're in the US
dollar currency and they suggest or they
are quoting a yougov poll for the Times
which gives labor a 17 point lead over
the Tories the biggest recorded
um so far
um you know you know should we listen to
someone like Andy Burnham who said that
this was you know economically Reckless
socially Reckless and politically
Reckless
well the Tory party have uh scored an
unbelievable own goal
um as labor having their conference
um you know if labor cannot exploit this
uh for the most political points
possible
um then they really need to get out of
politics forever uh it looks like they
will I mean the polls suggest uh uh I
think you gov is the highest ever lead
for labor since they've been doing that
poll is that right
um and uh I would also like to point out
that the Stars punt on the pound is a
lot better than the pound quad tanks
because I think is terrible
uh as a pub
um but uh Honey I Shrunk The quids from
the stars is a lot stronger yeah I
still made everybody before here to be
honest with you but there we are
um the express though uh coming out in
support
um uh Don't Panic we have got a plan to
cut debt is that is that is that the one
that we're going to hear on November the
23rd
um the uh Daily Telegraph uh not so
happy spooked lenders ditched new
mortgages in pound chaos but they quote
the uh the statement from the bank of
England and the treasury the monetary
policy committee will not hesitate to
change interest rates by as much as
needed to return inflation to the two
percent Target what are we looking at
then now Susie six percent
um is that the suggestion
that's the suggestion six six and a half
percent
um and although that is about that's
about three times interest rates at the
moment although it may seems like a
small amount perhaps still to some
people if you don't have a mortgage six
percent doesn't seem like enormous
that's still halfway to the the really
crippling interest rates we had in the
in the early 90s uh of about 14 15
um after uh black Wednesday and so it
causes a huge correction to house prices
to the availability of borrowing one of
the things they've done by devaluing the
pound in this way unintentionally is
they've increased the cost of government
borrowing so just at the time that they
borrowed tens of billions more they've
managed also to increase the cost of
doing it and it was already out of high
for having to borrow that money to start
with so it's it's a double kind of
incompetence but there is a fantastic
quote actually in the front of the Ft
from um the chief Economist at the bank
of Singapore who says it looks like
we're headed for a spiral that we
usually see in Emerging Markets
um where policy makers struggle to
reassert credibility and I think that
says absolutely everything about where
we are what's astonishing is that this
is a government that's managed to do
this uh two and a half weeks after they
took over what were they thinking
well the Daily Mail in its own way being
supportive blaming City Slickers betting
against the UK PLC speculators profiting
from a fall in the pound do you blame
them Freddie or is there something
specific that happened on Friday that
caused this because a lot of it was
factored in the business help on Energy
prices we heard about already we knew
that National Insurance would be ditched
that increased that corporation tax the
future rise would be ditched so what was
it specifically that the markets do you
think on Friday
um I think actually it's the combination
of the energy plan uh the sheer cost of
that and then no clear way in which uh
the government put out that they were
going to pay for this huge increase in
spending
um there is actually some good news this
is a tiny bit of good news for Britain
and I think everybody should be uh
relieved a bit by this which is gas
prices going down quite dramatically
um today so let's hope that continues
because that will make uh the burden of
the energy cap much lower
um I I think however on the
um General reaction to the to to the the
mini budget
there's no there's the government just
didn't see this happening they didn't
anticipate it
um and I think that's rather
short-sighted of them uh and it also
suggests I mean I do think so in terms
of like you can't blame actually Freddie
Rishi sunak is trending on Twitter right
now because everybody pointed out that
he pointed out numerous times throughout
that campaign the fairy tale economics
the dive in the pound the guilt increase
Etc you know how they weren't aware of
the warnings
um you know Beggar's belief does it not
it doesn't I mean I don't think you can
I don't think you can blame speculators
for speculating and so on I do think uh
there does tend to be a bit more um as
somebody on Blue Book to put it today
there's you know we need rather more
numbers and fewer adjectives I think
there's a lot of apocalyptic talk
um about this Sterling crisis and it is
a crisis uh but I don't think we're
quite a Britain default levels yet which
is what you would get if you read uh
quite a few of the newspapers today well
crisis is the word the guardian is using
on its front cover Sterling crisis
deepens as trust's strategy unravels but
it's the right hand column you wanted to
pick out
um Susie up in Liverpool as you are for
the labor Party Conference uh which is
the words of kierstama he will attempt
to take on the mantle of Tony Blair tell
us more
yeah he's going to say basically that
um you know the labor party now is the
the party of fiscal responsibility and
he's going to say that the conservatives
have lost control of the economy they've
crashed it it's over
um and they've done it all just for the
sake of some tax cuts for what you know
a few thousand uh super rich people and
you've got to bear in mind the tax cuts
that were that was penciled for coming
in who knows if they're actually still
coming now or not we can have a
government by Christmas I don't know but
that was for you know people earning
over 150 000 pounds a year it affected
maybe half a million people and you've
got to also ask yourself how many people
earning more than 150 000 pounds take
that money is paye and therefore pay the
income tax how many people own that kind
of money spend every single penny of it
in the UK how many of them actually save
their monies they never spend it at all
how many of them actually managed to
find find a way to shelter some of that
money so it's away from the tax man you
know the the idea that letting those
people have more money and it would all
trickle down upon us only works if
everybody in in the economy is in a
bubble and no one moves their money
offshore and no one buys things from
Amazon and nobody goes to buy coffee
from Starbucks and there are no
multinationals that move their profits
offshore and get them taxed offshore
there is no such thing as true good and
economics it's been proved wrong again
and again and again and the fact that um
I mean Freddie was saying that there was
sort of short-sighted and didn't see
what was coming I would dispute that I
think they have seen exactly what was
coming Reuters reported earlier this
week that OD Asset Management which is a
big hedge fund which quasiquarting used
to work for
um soared in value by 145 after shorting
the pound now quasi uh I'm sure didn't
give him any information about what he
was doing but I'm sure also that OD
Asset Management knew the kind of thing
he was going to go and do once he got
into some kind of position of power and
they may make a very good guess and it
was very well signposted as you said
Anna exactly the kind of cuts that were
going to come in he knew what was coming
they knew it was going to go bad it
shorted the pound they made and now that
government cannot possibly turn around
and blame as they have done on the front
page The Daily Mail the the City
Slickers for talking the pound down
because the reason the pound's down is
because what the government did okay
Susie and Freddie stay there lots more
to talk about including this why anyone
needing a new mortgage could face
problems as a result of the market
terminal sure you're aware back with
that in just a moment
[Music]
thank you
you're watching the Press preview with
me once again the deputy editor of The
Spectator Freddie gray and the Daily
Mirror columnist Susie Boniface welcome
back to both of you
um so uh well we returned to a theme I'm
afraid but new mortgages for certain
companies are blocked earlier today
Freddie because of this Market turmoil
the I listing Halifax virgin money and
Skipton had stopped offering new home
loans
um what are they waiting to do see how
it all Settles
well I think this is going to be the the
big Financial story of the next few
months which is what is going to happen
if as the market anticipates rates go up
some people anticipating the
government's highest of seven percent uh
that with that will cause uh enormous uh
damage and harm to the British economy
uh it could precipitate a housing crash
some people think that uh this trust is
uh quite sanguine about a sharp dipped
in housing prices that's that's the
point of debate
um but the issue of mortgages is
something that could really [ __ ]
um a large chunk of the British
population and the the difference
between the 1970s and now is that people
have much bigger mortgages and that
their payments will be uh enormous and
in fact unpayable so there'll be large
amounts of defaulting and possibly a
huge housing crisis
just when you want to be cheered up
um let's go on to the time it doesn't
get any cheery I know um again the times
uh quoting the bank vancou step in after
a day of turmoil
um reminding us that uh Andrew Bailey
Bank of England Governor ruled out an
emergency rate rise said he will not
hesitate to change interest rates and
your paper
um as well Susie out of control uh pound
at record lows new interest rate fear
and millions of households braced for
more price hike so that's the the nuts
and bolts of it for people now isn't it
exactly and you know one of the
occurrences that pound fell against
today was the Russian ruble
the currency of a country which is
currently undertaking and losing an
industrialized war and issuing nuclear
threats and raping and kidnapping women
and children as young as four and their
currency did better than ours today
I don't know what to say quite frankly
at the moment but there we are it's uh
yeah it's one of those Center front
pages isn't it definitely
um Freddie Susie thank you both very
much indeed